en ese estadio el estadio de la
Argentina ha conseguido superar esa
semifinal contra Croacia Para volver a
una final en este mismo escenario fue en
donde todo empezó mal en esta copa mundo
de Qatar 2022 para la albiceleste aquí
fue en donde los dirigidos por escalón y
debutaron con derrota contra Arabia
Saudita se han sabido recuperar y ahora
de nuevo en este domingo ya sea contra
Francia o contra Marruecos van a tener
una oportunidad para levantar su tercera
copa mundo se dice ya la final fue otro
partido Igualmente antes del primer gol
fue muy parejo gracias manejó Ya la
pelota Tiene un gran medio campo Luca
modric en un nivel espectacular por
suerte pudimos abrir el partido y
después creo que fue otra cosa el
segundo tiempo Realmente Argentina para
mí fue el mejor segundo tiempo el mejor
tiempo que el mejor fútbol que le voy a
sacar en el mundial si hay algo que he
conseguido hacer esta selección
argentina de Lionel scaloni y Lionel
Messi es de transmitir esa Mística esa
buena energía a la afición sin duda
alguna la afición argentina se hace
sentir cada vez que va junto con
Marruecos son las mejores hinchadas que
hemos visto en esta copa mundo el sentir
en los hinchas es que se superó por fin
un partido sin sufrir no se sufrió
contra acrobacia como si se sufrió
contra Australia y contra Países Bajos
están en la final y algunos reconocen
que con un sacrificio económico que ha
supuesto para ellos llegar hasta aquí
pero dicen que ha valido la pena pausado
es algo único No sé no se puede explicar
lo que se siente
y además estamos viviendo en Argentina
que es un país que hoy por hoy no está
muy bien económicamente entonces cuesta
el doble todo nosotros lo sentimos
muchísimo cada vez que por ejemplo
cantan algo queremos seguir cantando y
creo que tenemos la mejor hinchada de
todo el mundial lejos lejos lejos
incluso gente otros países que viene
dice Argentina tiene la mejor hinchada
de todos los países